les tables sont espacées d'un mètre
entre chaque conseillers municipaux le
gel hydroalcoolique et les masques sont
de rigueur pour ce conseil
d'installation qui se déroulent au
gymnase de la malle me donne à maurepas
on est dans un lieu qui est beaucoup
plus ventilé ce qui permet aussi de
respecter les distanciation entre chaque
élu est ce qu'il va nous permettre
évidemment d'installer correctement le
conseil municipal d'élire le maire ses
adjoints et de commencer à travailler
le conseil a voté grégory garcia est élu
pour un deuxième mandat à maurepas
difficile de respecter les gestes
barrière au moment de passer l'écharpé
tricolore
il est à présent l'heure pour le maire
de mort pas de se concentrer avec ses
nouveaux adjoints et conseillers
municipaux sur les projets lancés lors
de son premier mandat
le réaménagement du carrefour de la
malle me donne ou encore la construction
du centre aquatique seront au coeur des
discussions et renouveler plus de 50% de
mon équipe et donc c'est important aussi
pour un maire de jalhay dire d'être sur
deux jambes une jambe de l'expérience et
l'autre jambe du renouvellement du
renouveau pour stimuler aussi la
créativité et peut aussi continuer à
développer de nouveaux projets donc en
tout cas je suis très satisfait de
n'avoir pu être élu dès le premier tour
grâce au mort passe bien pour qu'on
puisse justement continuer de faire en
sorte que mon repas soit une belle ville
équilibrée protéger dans son caractère
rural et en même temps modernes avec des
projets que nous avons lancé depuis 2014
et qui vont continuer parmi les groupes
d'opposition la liste maurepas dynamique
et solidaire arrivé 3e au scrutin
obtient 3 sièges au conseil municipal
c'est un conseil d'installation donc ce
ne sera pas un conseil politique
il s'agit de nommer le maire de nommer
les adjoints c'est essentiellement
le sujet en fait aujourd'hui des
délibérations et ensuite l'aspect
politique et viendra par la suite mais
évidemment il faut que cette
installation soit fait pour que la vie
municipale puisse reprendre son long
chemin naturel traditionnel
l'autre liste d'opposition ensemble en
avant maurepas a déposé pendant le
confinement un recours pour contester
des élections au conseil d'état